career of the legendary Irving Thalberg
lasted from 1918 to 1936 18 years the
career of the legend we honor here
tonight but the Thalberg Memorial Award
has lasted 60 years so far his name is
Dino De Laurentiis his legend lives has
films most influential independent
producer an energetic creative fountain
of film his passion for the entire
moviemaking process has made him one of
the most fascinating and fascinated
producers of all the time
ladies and gentlemen my dear good
friends the great Dino De Laurentiis
thank you thank you very much
with what is a big hug I thank you
darling
the a fantastic guy he's a great actor
he's a great human being
I want to say thank you to the Board of
Governor that is a great honor but my
gratitude to go to six beautiful women
they love me they give me hope my wife
you Marta my daughter Veronica
Rafaela Francesca Karolina little Dina
for the moment
I'm I must say I'd be very lucky in my
life three continents the trend the
culture through good times and also good
time but today wonderful times had the
privilege to work with the greatest
master for sale let me dedicate this
happy out to ditalion tremendously with
the hope with the hope they come back in
life with new talent fresh ideas
in my life I'm the proudest pleasure by
wanting to be with the opportunity to so
many young the director for the first
time and this able to say somebody the
big studio not be afraid about your
talent new mind young mind are the
future of tomorrow dreams remember it
winterberg himself was only 23 years old
when you remember Jeff finally let me
share this our director Paul people
talented people all the young working on
my film maybe on the camera thanks to
them hey to everybody go to buy tickets
specially for my movie thank you very
much good bye